>> Sean: MONICA CROWLEY HAS
A POWERFUL NEW OP-ED OUT ON
THE HILL INCREDIBLE ABUSES
ON WATCH BLIGHT ON LEGACY.
MONICA WRITES IN ALL THE
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THE
POLITICAL WEAPONIZATION OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
AND THE FBI ALLEGED
CORRUPTION AT THE HIGHEST
ECHELONS OF THOSE AGENCIES
AND SERIAL ABUSE OF THE
SECRET FISA PROCESS
SURROUNDING THE 2016
ELECTION.
ONE NAME HAS BEEN
CONSPICUOUSLY ABSENT.
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA.
HERE NOW WITH REACTION
SENIOR FELLOW AT THE LONDON
CENTER FOR POLICY RESEARCH
MONICA CROWLEY, JUDICIAL
WATCH’S PRESIDENT TOM FITTON
AND FLORIDA ATTORNEY GENERAL
PAM BONDI.
MONICA, LET’S START WITH
THIS BECAUSE, YEAH, IT’S ALL
TRUE, ISN’T IT, THAT SHE
RIGGED THE PRIMARY.
PAM CAN ANSWER THIS LATER.
BUT I HAVE NEVER HEARD OF AN
EXONERATION MONTHS BEFORE
INTERVIEWING THE MAIN PEOPLE
IN AN INVESTIGATION.
THAT ALLOWS HER TO CONTINUE.
SHE PAYS FOR RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT, RUSSIAN
PROPAGANDA, THAT GETS USED
FOR FISA WARRANT.
THAT HE THEN THE TELL THE
FISA JUDGE SHE BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR IT AND IT’S NOT
VERIFIED.
THAT’S ALL IN ORDER TO
DISRUPT THE 2016 ELECTION.
HOW DOES THIS GET TO OBAMA?
I THINK THE SUSAN RICE MEMO,
THE GRASSLEY GRAHAM MEMO
MIGHT BE GIVING US SOME
INSIGHT.
>> YEAH, YOU KNOW, SEAN, WE
HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THE
TWO SORT OF SURFACED THINGS
GOING ON HERE AND THE
PURPOSE OF THE WEAPONIZATION
OF THE DOJ AND THE FBI AND
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
ONE WAS TO PROTECT HILLARY
CLINTON FROM PROSECUTION AND
MAKE SURE SHE WAS, IN FACT,
THE CANDIDATE BECAUSE SHE
WAS JOINED AT THE HIP TO
OBAMA.
REMEMBER, THE BENGHAZI
ATTACK, REMEMBER THE KNOWING
AND REPEATED COMMUNICATIONS
OVER HER SERVER AND BY HER
PRIVATE EMAIL ACCOUNT.
SO THEY HAD TO PROTECT HER
IN ORDER TO PROTECT
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
IF SHE WERE GUILTY OF
COMMITTING FELONIES, THEN SO
WAS HE.
SO THEY HAD TO INSULATE HER.
AND THE OTHER PART OF IT, OF
COURSE, THEY HATED DONALD
TRUMP SO THEY WANTED TO
DERAIL HIM.
BUT NOBODY IS ASKING THE
BIGGER QUESTION AS TO WHY.
AND THAT’S WHAT I TRIED TO
GET ACROSS IN THIS COLUMN
TODAY AT THE HILL, SEAN,
WHICH IS THAT BARACK OBAMA
ESSENTIALLY FULFILLED THE
LONG HELD LEFTIST AMBITION
OF CHANGING THE NATION ON
THE LEFT WARD TRAJECTORY.
WHAT OBAMA HIMSELF CALLED
THE FUNDAMENTAL
TRANSFORMATION OF THE
NATION.
THERE WAS NO WAY THAT HE AND
HIS TEAM AND THE CLINTON
SQUAD ALSO WAS GOING TO
ALLOW THOSE 8 OBAMA YEARS OF
LEFTIST ACHIEVEMENTS BE
REVERSED BY NONE OTHER THAN
DONALD TRUMP.
>> Sean: PAM, ZERO DOUBT THE
EVIDENCE AND THE EMAIL
SERVER, I HAVE LISTED THEM
ENOUGH TIMES IN THIS
PROGRAM.
>> UM-HUH.
>> MULTIPLE FELONIES WERE
COMMITTED.
BUT THEN YOU HAVE THE FBI
DIRECTOR AND TRUMP HATING
HIGHER UP INDIVIDUAL PETER
STRZOK AND MISTRESS AND
ANDREW MCCABE TALKING ABOUT
INSURANCE POLICIES.
SO THE FIX IS IN.
>> RIGHT.
>> Sean: YOU ARE PROSECUTOR.
HAVE YOU EVER BEGAN
EXONERATION LETTER MONTHS
BEFORE YOU INTERVIEW THE KEY
PEOPLE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION?
IT NEVER MADE SENSE.
HER STAYING IN THE RACE,
PAYING FOR THE RUSSIA LIES
AND GO TO THE FISA COURT AND
WITHHOLD INFORMATION.
ISN’T THAT LYING BY OMISSION
TO A COURT.
>> SEAN, IT’S MORE THAN
LYING BY OMISSION.
WHEN THEY GO FOR A FISA
WARRANT, THEY HAVE TO SWEAR
UNDER OATH THAT THE FACTS
THEY ARE PRESENTING THE
JUDGE ARE TRUE.
AND I CAN’T BELIEVE THAT THE
JUDGE HASN’T PULLED THEM
BACK ALREADY IN TO COURT TO
UNDO WHAT’S HAPPENED.
IT’S RIDICULOUS.
AND A FISA WARRANT.
THAT’S ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS WE DO AS
PROSECUTORS BECAUSE YOU ARE
INVADING SOMEONE’S PRIVACY.
YOU ARE WIRETAPPING THEIR
PHONES.
YOU ARE LISTENING TO
EVERYTHING THEY DO.
THAT’S WHY THAT INFORMATION
HAS TO BE PURE AND CLEAN.
>> Sean: THE GRASSILY GRAHAM
MEMO SAYS THAT THE DOSSIER
WAS THE BULK OF INFORMATION
EVIDENCE AND SO THEY HAND
THIS OVER.
NOW, THREE MONTHS LATER, YOU
GOT JAMES COMEY.
>> RIGHT.
>> SAYING TO TRUMP IT’S NOT
VERIFIED AND SALACIOUS.
BUT IT’S ONLY A FOOTE NOTE
AS WE UNDERSTAND IT TO THE
FISA COURT.
IT MAY HAVE POLITICAL
ORIGINS.
THEY KNEW HILLARY BOUGHT IT.
THEY KNOW SHE PAID FOR IT.
THEY KNEW IT WAS EVEN
PROBABLY NOT VERIFIED BUT
THEY DIDN’T TELL THE JUDGE.
WHAT SHOULD HAPPEN NOW?
>> WELL, THE JUDGE NEEDS TO
BRING THEM BACK BEFORE HIM.
THEY SHOULD ALL BE HELD IN
CONTEMPT AT VERY MINIMUM FOR
BRINGING FALSE INFORMATION
TO A JUDGE.
THAT’S MORE THAN LYING BY
OMISSION.
THEY DID NOT GIVE THE JUDGE
ALL THE FACTS.
I BELIEVE IT WAS VERY
FALSIFIED WHAT THEY DID.
IT NEEDS TO GO BACK BEFORE
THE JUDGE AND NEEDS TO BE
WIPED OUT.
EVERYTHING YOU ALWAYS HEAR
FRUIT OF THE POISONOUS TREE
PRINCIPLE.
EVERYTHING THAT CAME OUT OF
THAT WARRANT WAS FRUIT OF
THE POISONOUS TREE.
>> Sean: WOULD THAT MEAN
FLYNN’S GUILTY PLEA OUT THE
WINDOW.
>> EVERYTHING.
I REALLY CANNOT BELIEVE IT
HASN’T BEEN BROUGHT BACK
BEFORE THE JUDGE NOW THAT
YOU REVEALED AND FOX AND
EVERYONE HAS REVEALED ALL OF
THE FACTS.
>> Sean: MEMO IS THERE.
TOM FITTON.
DID I SEE THE PRESIDENT
TWEETING YOU THIS WEEKEND.
CONGRATULATE LEGS, MORE
IMPORTANTLY YOU ARE DIGGING
DEEP TO GET -- WILL WE EVER
GET A LOOK AT HOW WAD THIS
FISA MEMO WAS?
ARE THE ARGUMENTS MADE
BEFORE THE COURT.
IS THAT SOMETHING MAYBE IN
REDACTED FORM WE COULD LOOK
AT TO PURPOSEFULLY SEE WHAT
THEY TOLD THIS JUDGE?
>> WE SUED FOR THEM.
DEMOCRATS WILL HAVE THEIR
MEMO EVENTUALLY COME OUT.
WHY IS IT RELYING ON SUMMARY
DOCUMENT.
GET THE UNDERLYING
INFORMATION.
NUNES HAS ASKED FOR IT WE
SUED IN COURT FOR IT.
I TOLD THE WHITE HOUSE THAT
THEY SHOULD TAKE THIS
APPROACH OF EXTREME
TRANSPARENCY ON RUSSIA GATE.
IT DOES NOTHING TO PROTECT
THE PRESIDENT FROM THE
ACTIVITY AGAINST HIM AND
PROTECTS PEOPLE LIKE BARACK
OBAMA AND JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
AND FBI THAT WAS MISUSED TO
TARGET PRESIDENT TRUMP.
YOU KNOW, BARACK OBAMA --
THE DOSSIER IS CENTRAL TO
THE RUSSIAN COLLUSION
THEORY.
IT’S COLLAPSING AND IF IT
WAS CENTRAL TO THE RUSSIAN
COLLUSION THEORY.
WE HAVE REPORTS TODAY
QUICKLY SEAN, BARACK OBAMA
WAS GIVEN THE DOSSIER.
HE WAS GIVEN THE DOSSIER.
WHAT DID HE KNOW AND WHY
ABOUT IT.
IT.
>> Sean: THAT’S A GOOD
POINT.
THE GRASSLEY GRAHAM LETTER
TO RICE TODAY, MONICA
CROWLLY, THEY WANT TO KNOW
WHAT WAS TALKED ABOUT ON
JANUARY 5TH AND SUSAN RICE
NOTE TO SELF-JUST HOURS
BEFORE THEY LEAVE THE WHITE
HOUSE.
DOESN’T THAT SEEM A LITTLE
ODD THAT LETTER THAT SHE IS
ENDING OUT?
>> YEAH.
LOOK, THE IDEA, SEAN, THAT
ANY OF THESE PEOPLE IN THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH UNDER
PRESIDENT OBAMA,THE BRANCH
HE OVERSAW THAT ANY OF THESE
PEOPLE, COMEY, LYNCH,
MCCABE, THE LIST GOES ON,
STRZOK, PAGE, OHR THAT ANY
OF THESE PEOPLE FREELANCED
THIS WITHOUT AT LEAST THE
TACIT APPROVAL OF THE
PRESIDENT OR HIS WHITE HOUSE
REALLY STRANGE CON CRUEL TO
AT THIS HERE.
>> Sean: PAM, YOUD ME THIS
4RER9.
SUSAN RICE’S EMAIL SHE SENT
TO HERSELF IN THE WANING
HOURS OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
HOW DO YOU INTERPRET IT MY
INTERPRETATION IS CYA.
>> OF COURSE THAT’S WHAT IT
IS.
TO SAY THAT THE PRESIDENT
UNITED STATES BARACK OBAMA
DIDN’T KNOW WHAT WAS GOING
ON IS LUDICROUS.
THAT’S WHY MONICA’S
BRILLIANT OP-ED MADE SO MUCH
SENSE.
FUNDAMENTAL TRANSFORMATION
OF A NATION.
THAT’S WHAT PRESIDENT OBAMA
WANTED TO DO.
CYA ALL OF THEM.
HILLARY ELECTED SO HE COULD
NOT ONLY PROTECT HIS LIBERAL
AGENDA BUT ALSO TO PROTECT
HIMSELF FROM EVERYTHING THAT
THE COUNTRY WOULD FIND OUT
THAT HE HAD DONE.
>> Sean: GOING TO COVER UP